we are live welcome Kevin thanks a lot
Quincy how's it going it's going great
so Kevin is an amazing communicator and
teacher he is the founder of RTF manual
do where he creates amazing analogies
for programming concepts he also has
really awesome interactive tutorials
that you should check out I've linked to
all those below but let's talk a little
bit about you man so Kevin you started
out as an environmental science and
entrepreneurship major at U Michigan and
you you joined to startup and you had to
basically learn how to do software
development right off the bat tell us a
little bit about that
yeah sure so I was a liberal arts guy in
school he said when I was school out at
Michigan and actually right out of
university I founded a company called
diverging with a technical partner and
what ended up happening was you know we
were two 22 year old guys he was
fortunately a computer science major and
what ended up happening was you know
we'd over it into it and we quickly
realized that the backlog was stacking
up and my partner's Key's skill set was
back-end and we kind of looked at each
other and said you know we can wait for
a while to get the front-end right or we
can find some other way to get around
this and I said you know if this is the
one thing that matters most and that's
gonna help move us forward then I'll
learn some code so I jumped in I started
with resources like code Academy code
school I don't think there was free code
camp at that point or if there was I
didn't know about it and you know just
started teaching myself being a CEO
during the day and trying to move the
business forward and then learning at
night and what would happen was I would
you know try to do as much as I could
between the hours of 7 p.m. and 1 a.m.
let's say I would come back you know
having learned a few things but
struggling with a bunch more
you know put some stuff in front of my
partner and he would help me out and
then eventually I got there but it was a
very much like a trial and error
experience and a lot of you know this is
the same struggles that everyone goes
through when they learned to code but
I'd say for me you know one of the big
things was knowing that the next day I
was gonna go and look my partner in the
face and have to tell them about you
know what progress I made and like you
know how I'm gonna solve the problems
for the business so that's a pretty big
motivator well you know it's just two
people in a room basically Wow
so to recap you you basically put
yourself in a situation where you're
forced to rise to the challenge jump
right in and the well-being of your
venture is largely contingent on your
own ability they to grok a lot of these
concepts and apply them yeah yeah yeah
and just the cycle of you know learn a
few front-end skills improve the user
interface do a user test and realize how
far I still have to go and then you know
pick up the next few things so it was it
was you know learning it in real time
for sharing so you're now at an another
company um but on nights and weekends
you put on your back cape and you run
our TF manual die oh yeah this is an
amazing collection of analogies many of
your analogy articles which we published
on free cooking at medium convocation
and they've been extremely popular how
did you decide to go out and teach
coding yeah so I started at this new
company June last years I've been here
about eight months and I was kind of
thinking about you know the challenges I
had learning to code obviously on nights
and weekends in the first place and I
said there's an internet full of content
out there and there's sites like free
code camp and code Academy and all that
but still a huge struggle you know what
are all these sites what are they not
covering why is this still so
challenging and I just thought about
what I you know I have a marketing
background and I thought about what I
could personally offer and I just try to
take it from a different approach you
know I was and maybe you experienced
this as well Quincy a lot of
resources on the internet try to explain
technical terms with other technical
terms and it just you end up reading the
article like four times over before you
may or may not get it and I said you
know for a beginner I just have to to
set that frame of reference like what
are people even looking at and I wanted
to avoid you know they can always learn
the technical terms later I wanted to
find a way to make it really clear and I
thought you know just a couple creative
ways to do that I didn't want to be just
another guy writing content on the
Internet and I said you know a lot of
times analogies help people so what if I
just strictly focused on analogies and
put a lot of effort into building great
analogies and making that the core focus
and so you know like any entrepreneur
what I did to test it was I just the
first article I made was called
JavaScript callbacks explained using
minions and so it's for people that you
know after you're an experienced
developer callbacks make a lot of sense
but for any newbie it can take you a
while to get it and it's obvious after a
while and I said alright let's just put
this out there and see what happens and
I got considering that was my first
piece of content that I had ever really
posted it got a pretty strong response
got a bunch of people sharing on you
know Twitter I said I might be onto
something here and then you know after
that I was able to reach out to yourself
you know who was really nice and letting
me post in the free code camp
publication and a couple other people in
at places like site point and whatnot
and they all loved the concept and I was
like I guess I'm onto something here so
it was really nice to have that
validation from people like yourself but
it was started with just you know I
think this might be interesting but I'll
you know try to write one of them and
see what happens yeah and since then
you've written a wide variety of
analogies just off the top of my head I
can think of a lot of them you explain
CSS using an ice cream sundae yeah yes
yeah popular you arrived a model view
controller using yeah drinks at a bar
yep and and some of these people just
write to me and say like finally I get
it like I wonder what the heck the
relationship behind betwee
these things was and now yeah I'm I'm
working with it I envisioned myself
manipulating a Sunday that's what I'm
looking for I guess the way I thought
about it it's kind of like exactly what
you said like people understand these
relationships between existing things
like an ice cream sundae or an ordering
a drink at the bar and I didn't want to
try to teach coding as an entirely new
system and say oh yeah there's these
highly technical things and here's what
they do because that's when it gets
exhausting right I wanted to say hey it
just fits into this system that you know
and all you have to do is learn the
syntax and stuff like that and go from
there and a lot of technical writers I
can say this because I I read maybe a
hundred articles holy medium publication
and a lot of people like will use
they'll use a lot of jargon and the
point to other articles and at some
point my question for them is why should
people read your article instead of just
going and reading Wikipedia entry
because that's what Wikipedia is it's
basically exactly whole bunch of it
early jar yeah but it's not particularly
accessible to a newcomer exactly yeah
yeah that's right and you've also
created some interactive tutorials where
you can actually go in and basically
step by step you can interact with the
analogies this is really cool and you
did all the design of your stuff which
is really impressive like all the assets
you see when you go to RTF manual do
those assets were created right here by
Kevin yeah exactly and the way I figured
out if you know that might be worth my
time was people would either send me an
email or they would comment on the
medium post and say wow this is an
interesting article but I love it if
there's a way that I could participate
in it and you know make it interactive I
said oh wow you know that's a good next
step because that's a more active
learning method it would probably be a
little more fun for people to do it
going along so I just said you know all
right that's a good idea I'll find a way
to do it and
so what you're describing is essentially
like Lean Startup methodology right Leah
the people who are using your product
and making product design decisions
based on that feedback yeah exactly and
especially with something that seems
this crazy right you know at the
beginning I was like am I just insane or
is this actually gonna help people and
the easiest way for me to that quickly
validate that was you know just putting
out one block and then what I found was
you know from reaching out to people
like yourself and a couple features at
like General Assembly and first step
coding they all said oh we try to
integrate analogies into our lessons and
this is just like brings that to a whole
new level so that you know the experts
were already doing it and it fits in
exactly with what they do so how do you
come up with the analogies like you just
sit in the bathtub and rock back and
forth how does it happen
there's like there's the different
phases in it it goes through my head as
well because I'll you know think of a
concept like CSS positioning that I want
to explain and sometimes it can take a
couple days and I like creep into the
self-doubt phase though there's no good
way to do this and then inevitably I
find something and honestly it you like
from the creative process you just have
to like get yourself in different
situations and pull your brain different
ways and I'm trying to think if there's
one way that I do it I you know I play
soccer so I like play soccer and then
think about it on the train ride home
pace around my apartment but it takes a
while like there there's definitely a
creative process and I'd say the biggest
thing you know you know like if I decide
if something's good enough an allergy or
not is I really feel like people have to
understand the different pieces they
have to understand the relationships
between different pieces and these
aren't one-dimensional analogy is where
it's just like I'll give an example out
of people say like variables are like a
bucket where you just plop a value in
bucket and all that that's true that
doesn't tell you anything about like the
relationship between the entire system
so the one biggest you know parameter I
use is can people understand the
relationships between the elements in
the system like an ice cream sundae
people know the
the scoops the cherry these people
understand how those things relate to
each other right and that's the key to a
good analogy as opposed to analogy that
just kind of falls flat like what I
would call like a low effort analysis
even the bucket level is more helpful
than trying to like explain an a
variable in a very technical way right
even a bucket is better than then trying
to make it a big technical system but
I'm trying to agreed so I mean I applaud
their effort but they need to go the
next level and hopefully people won't
have to reinvent these wheels hopefully
they'll just use some of your amazing
analogies love this yeah incorporate it
into you know courses exactly University
classes and stuff yeah so let's talk
about your motivations and aspirations
behind creating this projects you
already have a full time job going home
nights and weekends and you're thinking
of these crazy analogies and you're
questioning your sanity while you're
thinking about stuff like that
talking company a little bit about how
how you decided to do this and what gets
you up and going every day
yeah I the way here's the way I think
about it and you know how I think it
might be able to help people most
directly is what would happen when I was
starting my previous company was I would
come home after you know doing business
stuff and that like 7:00 p.m. start
trying to learn code and then by 1:00
a.m. I need to go to bed it would always
be very unclear if I got anywhere on any
given night and sometimes we run into a
roadblock and you just say oh wow now
I'm gonna have to wait till tomorrow to
get my partner to explain this to me
because I have no idea and a lot of
people don't have a technical partner
you know they can sit down with and get
an explanation from and so what I wanted
to do was bring in some sort of
predictive quality of just saying you
know what if I if I'm working from 7:00
p.m. to 1:00 a.m.
I better get something out of it you
know I better learn something and so I
was thinking of if I can set this
expectation in someone's head like
callbacks if they just have an idea
where the callbacks thing is going
they're much more likely to like feel
they're progressing along their coding
journey as opposed to Jess oh man I'm
running into a roadblock I don't know
you know what the next step is or if I'm
even thinking about this correctly but
they can say you know what if I put in
the hours here I'm gonna get somewhere
so that was kind of the motivation for
me and and you know at a greater level
it's creating a different a different
way to learn I'm not sure how to put it
well I talked about the neuroscience
behind it now yeah because like the the
human brain is essentially like a
relational engine and that's how we yeah
it is through relationships literally
neurons connecting with one another yeah
and this is something that I learned
midway through the process that
encouraged me to keep on doing the weird
little analogies is what's a call it's
called is associative memory and so your
brain it makes a lot easier to recall
information if it's stored in a system
and what I thought was like when you
know you traditionally teach a new
coding topic let's say CSS positioning
you teach it one by one people would say
hey this is what position:absolute is
missus what relative is and just like go
at it one by one and what I wanted to do
is quickly get all those relationships
into people's brains at once and so it's
much easier for them to recall later and
what I realized was that the analogies
that's why people like them so much is
because it already taught them those
those relationships they didn't have to
form them themselves and like magically
discover it they could just say oh yeah
now I understand you know how these two
things relate do you have any any
specific advice for people who are
learning to code maybe little tricks to
leverage the neuroscience to to learn a
little bit faster in terms of little
tricks begin using my tutorials is the
best I have right now I'm trying to you
know like a better expert on this meat
than me might be Tim Ferriss or
something like that but the biggest
thing for me it's kind of like the
difference between memorization and
understanding is you can like pack
together and user interface let's say
and like you know build it once but if
you want to like feel like you have a
grasp for some
you're gonna have to understand it
eventually and so I just think that you
know it just depends where you want to
cross that that bridge you know you're
gonna have to fill that understanding
and I think it might be better to do it
upfront and really try to understand the
whole system when you can but otherwise
you might say yourself out for a long
like facing one challenge at a time
right and I think that it's extrinsic
pressure putting putting yourself in a
situation where people are depending on
you to learn effectively it was a
technique to kind of coerce yourself and
still hurting faster I would say the one
biggest thing is just like have a
project that you're motivated to move
towards and that you want to see happen
and that's for me you know it was
obviously in my business is that I guess
I could wait for a long time for my
technical partner to get to that part or
I could just say you know this is the
one thing that's holding our business
back I need to learn and so for me you
know just just putting it right into a
project and and something that I that
meant a lot to me that was everything
because otherwise you know those those 7
p.m. to 1 a.m. nights become really
exhausting and that's the one thing that
really pushed me forward was focusing on
you know that that goal that me and my
partner were building and based on your
experience teaching yourself were there
any strategies you found in addition to
applying these analogies that just
really helped you understand and and
learn yeah I I really like the active
active learning methods you know just
like doing something like free code camp
or code Academy or any of those but
something that's going to get you
immediately involved and I think I like
what free code camp does with you know
the community of being able to show it
to someone and say hey we're a community
of people that are even if we're
accomplishing small projects where we're
moving along so I would say that's a big
thing like do not put yourself in a
and say I'm not opening at this door
until I know code because Yahoo that
will be a challenge but I think you know
just finding different reinforcements or
things you can feel good about you know
just just finding successes along the
way that's that's everything because in
my case you know the success might have
been getting a user interface or a
wireframe ready to be tested with users
and of course it would get thrown right
back in my face right the users would be
like this isn't good but I was just
proud that I had something that they
could use and I could get feedback on
and move my project forward and that's
that's huge you know the after that I
can take that constructive criticism
until the next thing so you know having
that kind of intermediate goal that's
really important right on so just to
recapitulate what you said just having
basically having kind of psychological
checkpoints you cross and getting
feedback and not putting yourself in the
peroneal room so there was a great
question on Quora somebody asked how can
I learn to code in one day and the
answer was hilarious it's like go
directly to the North Pole and prop up
your chair in your satellite internet
connection you have three months of day
find a place for a three month day yeah
so it's important I mean I'll just I'll
just totally echo what Kevin said it's
absolutely important that you get
involved and you get feedback from
people and that you don't you know the
Chinese have a very important expression
that I always like to cite quad mutton
haiku our zeta Plumbing's ITER
which means to close the doors and to
build the chariot indoors of course you
never know if your charity is actually
good and so you take it out and you
drive it but yeah this one guy from
Chinese Lord just spent months and
months building this chariot and of
course the second he took it out to
drive it it just fell apart yeah you
know if you're not constantly getting
feedback and asking people for input and
things like that you're you're kind of
building the chariot behind closed doors
yeah what's on the what's on the agenda
Woori what are your top priorities with
our TF manual right now yeah so I
definitely want to cover more topics of
you know the basics whether it's from
JavaScript CSS I've got a sequel article
coming up I've got to get one like a git
very basics coming up but I think the
greater thing is to just turn those into
interactive tutorials and something that
someone can participate in like I just
remember all the time struggling when I
was learning of not understanding the
system and I would do something silly
like mix JavaScript and jQuery and my
partner would go those are written
differently you can't just throw those
together just because it's all in one
javascript file you know those are
slightly different and you know just
helping people along with interactive
tutorials I think is the next big thing
and and what I'm looking for is if that
can actually help people learn faster so
rather than you know searching for
articles or you know trying to do
whatever you can to find stuff on the
Internet just saying you know here's a
simple system that'll the tone for you
and then after that it'll be a lot
easier to learn like all the little
technical nitty-gritty but just to have
a level of expectation so I feel like
the big idea here is it's starting with
content but moving towards an
interactive tutorial system that people
can participate in and then feel good
about the progress that they're making
and understand that if they do put in
the hours they'll get there it isn't
just a series of running into walls
right on well everybody be sure to check
out some of Kevin's articles below I
strongly recommend the CSS positioning
with an ice cream sundae one of my
favorites that's a great place to start
and then just dive through as many as
you're interested in doing you'll learn
a lot of cool concepts in a lot of very
memorable ways that'll any through
familiar with the concept it might help
further solidify it also below I've got
a Twitter account for Kevin I strongly
recommend you follow him I follow him
and he also has a mailing list which I
signed up for and you should sign up for
two if you enjoy his work
and check out his interactive tutorials
he's got one on JavaScript that involves
minions like minions from Despicable Me
in the movie which were eager to show my
daughter once he when she is old enough
to keep the fun enough so thank you so
much for joining us Kevin it's been a
pleasure talking to you and learning
more about everything you're doing and
thank you for all the great work you're
doing Internet helping people learn
yeah and Quincy I really just appreciate
your support from an early stage when a
few people knew about what I did and you
jumped on board early I really
appreciate that
absolutely I'm thrilled to help help
signal boost and help people discover
the great work you're doing so have a
beautiful day thank you for joining us
thank you everybody for tuning in
yeah thanks so much guys